we've got some info here from the
wall street journal because uh what
biden is doing is just compounding the
problem over and over again let's get to
it president biden is scrambling to
contain soaring oil prices which closed
at more than 123 dollars a barrel on
monday it speaks volumes about his
administration that it's seeking help
from vladimir putin's client in
venezuela
and our estranged saudi allies rather
than u.s shell producers or canadian
friends that's right that's right come
back to me for one second yes because
now russia is bad guys we going to
venezuela because suddenly they're good
guys okay let's keep going the trump
administration in early 2019 sanctioned
venezuela's state oil company pdvsa to
squeeze nicolas maduro's brutal regime
which has impoverished the country
persecuted political opponents and sent
millions of refugees across the region
come back to me for just a sec but we're
cool with that now because they're not
russian so it's all good we'll buy your
oil okay but venezuela continues to pump
about 800 000 barrels a day
with help from russia and iran the
venezuelan has returned the favor by
supporting mr putin's war on ukraine and
denounce the west's economic war against
the russian people come back to me for a
second so you see what's happening here
we're buying or we're going to buy gas
from venezuela who are kind of in
cahoots with putin in the first place
but okay let's keep going axios also
reports that the president is
considering a personal visit to saudi
arabia to patch up relations with the
crown prince whom mr biden has made a
show of disdaining when he took office
at the same time the administration has
been seeking reproachment with iran
which backed the houthis in yemen waging
war against the kingdom and united arab
emirates so you know these are all great
people that we'll be working with you
know because putin bad i get it putin
not good you can't just invade a country
i mean all right joking aside for a
second you can't just invade another
sovereign nation you can't he's killing
all sorts of innocent people i don't
want to diminish that actually um but
this idea that we're pivoting to all the
other bad people some of whom are
funding some of the stuff in russia in
the first place
if this was a script you'd go man it's
just too obvious like it just shows
their incompetency just too well
here's fox news's peter ducey who's an
actual journalist we got to get him on
the show can we get peter ducey on the
show do we have a phone number or an
email address let's get that guy uh
talking to jen saki
about uh the keystone xl pipeline and
what happened there
there's this talk about a possible
forecast for financial pain particularly
the gas pump yeah for americans um the
president said today the notion that
this is going to last for a long time is
highly unlikely
would he try to ensure that
by lifting some of the restrictions that
he's put in place on the energy industry
or
rethinking some projects like the
keystone pipeline
well first of all the keystone pipeline
is not flowing so i'm not sure how that
would solve anything there's also plenty
of oil leases that are not being tapped
into by oil companies so you should talk
to them about that and why
but what the president's talking about
is we certainly understand and he said
this today right may have been in
response to your question i don't
remember but um if there's an invasion
of another country by a big country
there's going to be impacts on the
markets right and we certainly
anticipated that and we anticipate that
as it relates to the global oil market
as well so that's why the president for
weeks now has been engaging with a range
of big global suppliers some in the
middle east others to see what we can do
to ensure their supply out there in the
market to reduce the impact on the
american people
all right
saki you're making me do it i'm putting
on the newsman glasses to make a point
directly to you
you are a horrible horrible soulless
person i don't understand how someone
for a living could lie about literally
everything
your existential crisis must be massive
and i i know you hate yourself we can
see it we can see it on your face we can
see it
um the line there when he he's basically
saying ducey and why why are they all
wearing masks i have no freaking idea
doozy take off the mask i like you dude
but take the mask off um
the line he's basically saying to her
hey why don't we do something about that
keystone xl because you know that thing
would bring a lot of gas from canada we
wouldn't be so reliant on uh on russia
or venezuela or et cetera et cetera you
get what's going on here lady and she
goes uh the keystone pipeline isn't
flowing
yes no [ __ ] sherlock you people shut it
off